for the first time since Saturday's El
Paso shooting we are hearing from the
parents of the suspect in a statement to
the Wall Street Journal the family wrote
Patrick's actions were apparently
influenced and informed by people we do
not know and from ideas and beliefs we
do not accept or condone Janet shamlian
is in El Paso Janet good morning Dana
good morning the Walmart parking lot
here is slowly emptying as people who
survived the shooting are now able to
come back and pick up their cars
several Walmart's across the country
could be a bit emptier as well today
an employee group is calling for a
nationwide walkout over Walmart's gun
sales meanwhile here in El Paso emotions
are still very raw in the wake of this
tragedy
keyonna long couldn't hold back tears as
she finally returned to the Walmart
Tuesday for the first time since the
shooting to pick up the car she left
behind
authorities are learning more about the
alleged shooters movements after he
stormed the Walmart El Paso police
confirmed the suspect was driving a
Honda Civic about a quarter mile from
the store he reportedly stopped got out
of the car with his hands in the air and
surrendered to an officer on a
motorcycle
now as El Paso grieves some of the
injured are well enough to share their
stories I just feel grateful that I'm
alive he had the chance to kill me but
he didn't Octavio Ramiro lazar day was
shot in the foot and has had several
reconstructive surgeries the youngest
victim of the massacre 15 year old
Javier Rodriguez was his nephew I did
lose my nephew right in front of me
I'll put the details but his horrible
image and I hope nobody ever goes to
that pain is felt by the entire
community this morning including the
suspects parents who in that statement
to the Wall Street Journal also said
there will never be a moment for the
rest of our lives when we will forget
each and every victim of this senseless
tragedy
Jericka Janet thank you